checa power by después la madre de down
right relata la última conversación
telefónica con su hijo momentos antes de
que muriera a causa de un disparo de un
agente de policía entonces cuando volví
a llamar la chica que le acompañaba en
el coche contestó al teléfono y estaba
en facetime y estaba llorando y gritando
y dijo que le habían disparado y
apresuró el teléfono hacia el asiento
del conductor un hijo estaba atendido
allí sin responder esta fue la última
vez que vi a mi hijo
junto a ella y a la novia de ride otra
familia afligida la de georges floyd
saliendo en juzgado donde se lleva a
cabo el juicio contra la gente de erecto
bing
digamos
envidiables minneapolis ya no pueden
barrer esto bajo la alfombra estamos
aquí lucharemos por la justicia para
esta familia igual que estamos luchando
por nuestro hermano
thomas steitz un supuesto error un arma
a mano por una pistola eléctrica es
inaceptable hasta cuando no ven es
defender la policía de brooklyn center
ha dicho que la gente que disparó
mortalmente al raid durante un control
de tráfico rutinario el pasado domingo
había disparado su arma por error
pensando que era una pistola eléctrica
la gente quin potter así como el jefe de
policía team canon que fue criticado por
calificar el suceso de accidente
dimitieron el martes el alcalde de la
ciudad dijo que esperaba que estas
renuncias ayuden a sanar a la comunidad
pero la policía antidisturbios y los
manifestantes se enfrentaron de nuevo
por tercera noche consecutiva en las
continúan los llamados a la justicia y
decisión de cuentas